c'est avec la guerre des tuques que le
producteur connaît son premier succès en
1984 film culte au québec il se vend
aussi dans 125 pays c'est le premier
d'une longue série des contes pour tous
des longs métrages qui connaîtront de
nombreux succès populaires
internationaux telle opération beurre de
pinottes la grenouille et la baleine ou
bach et bottine
si brett lucien avant je m'enrichis 7
après des études en enseignement et en
faisant un voyage autour du monde dans
les années 60 que rock demers se
découvre un intérêt pour le cinéma
d'ailleurs et à son retour il crée la
compagnie faroun pour distribuer des
films étrangers ici déjà il a ses
critères de qualité sur un des éléments
essentiels que j'aime me retrouver dans
les films que je présente aux jeunes
c'est des films d'abord qui colle avec
la réalité et des films dans lequel ya
un certain merveille une certaine poésie
son intérêt pour le septième art l'amène
aussi à s'engager dans les institutions
vouées à son développement c'est ainsi
que rock demers devient un des
fondateurs de la cinémathèque québécoise
c'est un endroit où on pourrait
concerner les hommes dans leur
intégralité
ça a échappé au contrôle de l'ascenseur
il est aussi de l'équipe qui met sur
pied le premier festival de cinéma non
compétitif au québec le festival
international du film de montréal qui
connaîtra 8 édition annuelle jusqu'en
1967 dans tous les films seront des
premières nord américaines
mais c'est dans le cinéma jeunesse que
rock demers se trouve son filon et
développe sa passion il décide d'en
produire et fonde en 1981 la compagnie
des productions de la fête il en sortira
trente films en une trentaine d'années
une oeuvre saluée par des dizaines de
prix au pays et à travers le monde
punchy que l'on part une chronique avec
ses films rock demers voulait tisser des
liens entre les générations et entre les
cultures et toujours passer aux enfants
son message sur la beauté de la vie la
vie faut pas se raconter d'histoires
c'est pas facile mais ça vaut la peine
d'être vécue geneviève asselin radio
canada montréal